[Music]
Dave B just have we got any news on the
cast I they're not at that stage yet
they're not there yet so
um we know certain actors have been very
tentatively approached We Believe Amanda
tappin has been tentatively approached
and we believe Michael Shanks has and we
believe um actually know for a fact that
um the person whose name has now gone
out of my [__] head that played
Rush was Robert carile thank you was
approached about something I'm just
gonna cut in just cut in one second the
rush rumor was what then led to the
animated SGU movie rumor now something
that was said by this source that has
come to us from MGM was that one of the
things we we have talked about in the
last few months made them laugh quite a
lot that it was wrong now in the video I
did talking about this this rumor that
SGU was going to get its own animated
movie and this was going to be produced
by Warner Brothers was something that in
the video when talking about I actually
said I don't think this is true I very
much doubt this um but cuz it came
basically from a source I don't I don't
really know that well um and I don't
really I've never really vetted them
that well but in the video I did say I
spoke to somebody that is a little bit
more reliable who I do know um and they
said look it's possible because
remembering the Babylon 5 animated movie
was kept very secret so look that nobody
that I know well has heard this rumor
but they've all sort of said it's
possible but I doubt it now it looks
like MJ have confirmed that no we're not
getting an SGU animated movie
oh well back to the video though um but
it seemed to be that's when they were om
and iron about what storyline they were
going to do ah um in at the development
stage so they sort of very so they had a
few ideas and they seemed to be
approaching they like to go in if we did
this be interested sort of thing so no
more than that has been has been done
because obviously it's not there's no
point doing a massive script with Robert
carlle as rushing for some for whatever
reason even if it's only a small part if
he has no intention of doing it so You'
sort of tentatively sort of go would
would they be interested um and um so
we'll have to see but but we believe
that has but the casting won't happen
until
um basically after the strikes anyway
because all the actors are on strike so
they couldn't approach them
anyway or least they couldn't sign up I
don't know how it would work about sort
of like talking to agents and asking
whether there's probably been some sort
of like off the record conversations but
nothing
official yeah they can't legally do
anything official just yet almost yeah
but as there's a script you'd think that
at very least the one or two if there
are returning actors have been at least
tentatively approached and let's be
honest very few of them are going to be
busy enough to say
no Michaels is not saying no to this um
Manda tappin probably wouldn't even
though she's busy but no she wouldn't
see every every ComiCon she's done for
the last 10 years she says she's always
asked and she always says I'd be there
in a heartbeat um who would be too busy
to come back just thinking about it for
sake see what's on their on their IMDb
listing and full that's true I would
think I'll just off the top of my head I
would think M uh Michael judge
Christopher Judge would be a little
harder just because all his video game
stuff and he still acts a bunch um well
there's also the rumor going on that he
might end up being the God of War mhm so
um which I don't as much as it would be
great I just don't I don't see that
happening last time I heard they were
they were definitely tempted to approach
but then um the strikes
happened they were definitely willing to
at least have the conversation with him
so I I think it would be a popular
choice but it would be dangerous yeah
he's not young enough to carry something
like that I don't think right now he's
still built like a brick [__] house
built like a brick yeah but it it
depends I guess if they're going back
with like just the the the Norse god of
war aspect of things or if they're going
back further when Kratos need to be
younger I've never played the games but
I love the lore so they they could write
that around the person but um also
there's the fact that he's not very
Nordic in appearance
and CL
it um you put enough pain on somebody it
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day
honestly so anything about Fergus um I
asked I got smile and I got told they
couldn't answer
that that might be um just this is just
me just realizing actually there were
going to be legal reasons why they they
she can and can't or he can and can't
tell me certain things aren't there
because like if
penguin and AP Parker were actually
negotiating at the moment and it wasn't
all like signed yeah there might be
reasons why they they can't confirm that
because it maybe isn't even confirmed
I'm just thinking that there are
probably lots of legal reasons why they
can't say certain things well lot yeah I
mean don't want out there yeah a lot of
the things it's it's just everything's
frozen because of the strike you know
they may be take a
meeting but they wouldn't be able to
negotiate anything they wouldn't be able
to agree on anything but they could take
a Mee meeting and chat and talk but
there's lots of things they can't do
because of the strike and it would be
you know we saw what happened to Drew
Barrymore when she's oh yeah I'm just
gonna go into
production she was crucified there's
also gon be things they don't want o
dropping that they want to announce they
don't want they don't want a little
Channel with 26,000 subscribers to be
get the world exclusive on certain
things so I mean why they why they
wouldn't I don't know but and we've told
you literally everything else first so
you may as well you may just tell us um
but um but yeah there's going to be
certain things they don't want us to
announce yeah I mean it's all in talks
right until they actually sign things
and when they when they sign things they
put an IMDb Pro or IMDb in general so we
can look when they actually sign things
I know person You' spoken to Jay this
person right yeah you should ask them to
get Harris to be an actor in in St
because he's the only actor Among Us
I'll ask get him to I mean I want to be
in it as well but he's the only one with
any real
talent the amount of promotion I've done
for this I basically am now in the
opinion that this is only happening
because of basically me and in that case
I should be in
it I uh I I app myself to Jay to be
Jay's American liaison for anything and
everything MGM if there's a health and
safety guy in this movie
let me put my hat in the ring for you
over
here that' be awesome risk assessments
going oh you can't do that I gu the risk
assessment like come on they'll be doing
a briefing I'll interject and they'll
all go shut up
Matt just Jay being the new Syler just
somewhere in the back
just stuns and stuff as well getting
electrocuted gation and stuff so get
thrown across the gate yeah that be say
yeah I I I am going to have to ask but U
but yes haris why not why
[Music]
not